I'm so excited to try some Japanese
candy I am freaked out please
koala things not like hello panda so
they have to be good Oreo meets milo in
a koala shaped pod kind of like an Oreo
but a lot softer it reminds me of like
tiramisu yeah I could put away a whole
thing of that I reckon in one sitting
why koala though that's interesting niba
soda suppository yes yeah I like it it's
like a challenge it's like how long till
it goes away this is your normal
run-of-the-mill hard law you get on the
shop in Woolworths a guy with massive
biceps around his brain it looks like a
constipated brain one two three
mm-hmm why
it's like issued yeah tastes like what
Bo smells like like beef jerky yeah
Billy really salty very salty
I'm sure Japan like I love everything
else but look at this slow like this
cute little butt here you're just saying
oh I want to eat that but right
it's a personified butt and he's the
yolk I hope it's a but it's not a but
it's kind of got a life saver initial
flavor very citrusy mango mango right
yeah I'm going up it's tropical punch
just juice poppers
yes puddle is number one but well is
this is the kind of lollies that you
have during summer time or during winter
to remind you of summertime so I'm
hoping this is vegetarian looks like
dried seaweed for skin you just had to
say that before I put it in my mouth
I'm sorry is this candy oh the texture
so you must be a texture person because
that tastes really good
I don't know whether I'm having meat or
seaweed or dry skin like beef jerky see
what it tastes like salt and paper paper
salt
what's a be flavored KitKat this is my
jam I love wasabi
I love Kit Kats so this should be
delicious where's the wasabi dude okay
wait there it is definitely taste the
wasabi and it bloody works it's genius I
don't usually get the green tea ice
cream but I can put away definitely a
few of those up to some machine controls
yeah for sure
Japan's candy kill alert the Japan is
best food obviously I think that we're
just not used to some of the flavors
that like Japanese kids would yeah love
doesn't fancy it feels like there should
be a ring in there will you have a break
with me